[Music]
one of the things that most amazed by at
the moment is how the ideas and issues
that we're talking about every week here
on the Rubin report are relevant not
just in America but all over the world
the amount of email I'm getting from you
guys across the globe whether it's
Sweden Australia Brazil hungry or Japan
is actually staggering it really seems
to me that there has been a reawakening
as to what being a free human being is
all about you are in charge of your own
life and if you start with this simple
premise you can accomplish anything
while the discourse on social media may
seem more toxic than ever I see a
growing dynamic group of people coming
together through ideas and conversation
regardless of where they were born or
the color of their skin
we're partnering with learn Liberty
again this week and our guest is Rajshri
Agarwal she was born in India to a
traditional family only moved to America
where she now teaches about capitalism
at the University of Maryland where she
is the chair and professor of
entrepreneurship
she believes that capitalism provides
maximum freedom and happiness to all
people regardless of race religion or
anything else the ideas of freedom that
once sparked in her as a young child are
the same ideas that she's now helping
further by teaching minds of young
people today that is what freedom is all
about if you want to join me in
spreading these ideas of freedom and
individuality in person I'll be joining
Jordan Peterson on his twelve rules for
life tour for as many dates as I can
possibly fit in we kicked off the tour a
couple weeks ago at the beacon in New
York City where the energy in the room
was absolutely bananas I'll be traveling
with Jordan to the UK to speak in London
at the Apollo Hammersmith theatre on May
13th and then on May 14th I have the
incredible honor of speaking at the
Oxford Union hopefully I'll get to meet
as many of you guys as possible and I
also promise to down as many pints as
possible I'm also working on an
Australian tour and hope to have some
more info on that for you guys soon you
know I've mentioned on the show lately
that the endless hysteria of the left
and the politically correct craziness
that were caught up and was eventually
gonna drag me back into stand-up comedy
and this finally came to fruition this
past Sunday at the Irvine improv the
show was billed as an evening of stand
up and sit down
as I did about an hour of stand-up and
then Bob Saget joined me on stage for
about 45 minutes of a sit-down
it was awesome meeting so many of you
guys out there in the show was a huge
success the manager of the Improv even
told me that it was the first sold-out
standing ovation she's seen at the club
in her 18 years we're gonna announce
travel dates for upcoming stand-up gigs
pretty soon and I hope that you guys
will join me for at least a two-drink
minimum and plenty of laughs and finally
after years in the making we taped our
interview with dr. Thomas soul yesterday
on location at Stanford University in
San Francisco we flew our whole team up
there and rented a studio to make it
happen it was truly a personal and
career highlight for me and I can't wait
to share our sit-down with you next week
big thanks to our supporters on patreon
who make interviews like this possible
so all these announcements aside whether
you're in the US India Oxford San
Francisco or anywhere else we're all in
this fight together keep fighting for
what you believe in and I'll do the same
[Music]
you